Okay.
Thanks for coming along to this.
And so it's based on this book.
There are still some free copies left upfront if you want them.
So I was doing the research on this book when I was based in China at the top
business school there,
China,
Europe International Business School from 2011 to 2016.
Um,
so just to,
and the subtitle is really the theme of my talk from Imitation to innovation.
You used to hear about how China's like imitation nights about innovation.
In the early days,
of course China was just copying when it first,
you know,
from 1978 onwards,
the copying products were illegal sometimes of course,
Sean Gi,
which means mountain bandits.
Uh,
you see here a product called the block berry endorsed by President Obama
probably without his knowledge on the right,
something that surprises you.
This is not a cigarette packet pretending to be a moat,
a cell phone.
It's a cell phone pretending to be a cigarette packet just to show you how
different the Chinese can be.
They actually loves smoking so much.
Some of them wanted to pretend their cell phone.
It was a cigarette packets.
So then China starts moving from copying to fit for purpose.
So you know,
in the earlier days,
1980s,
1970s,
China was poorer,
lower per capita income.
So sort of practical innovations such as mood,
Guangdong,
crane,
moving from double welded a single weld.
It's a lot of process innovations.
China of course makes more solar panels than anybody else and the critical
innovation,
their self cleaning because if you have a dusty solar panel then that's a
massive problem.
So in the beginning,
these are not rocket science innovations,
but typical Chinese innovations,
they are pragmatic and profitable.
Um,
then you start seeing,
I'll talk a bit more later on about Alibaba Tao Bao.
These online systems where we start seeing innovation in online higher,
uh,
one of their biggest and probably the most international company,
major appliances.
Now the world's biggest major appliance companies.
Lots of initially small innovations.
Like early on they found that um,
their washing machines were getting clogged up in rural areas.
They discovered was because the farmers were using them to wash potatoes rather
than just clothes.
Now Western response might have been to put a label saying do not wash crops.
Instead,
their innovation was they changed the filter system and add a label saying
sooner for,
for both clothes and crops,
refrigerators.
When they first moved to the u s market,
they weren't at the lower end,
such as college dorm rooms.
And they realize that college dorms was small,
so they added a folding table top to double up as a desk or trivial innovation.
Today they have a more significant innovation,
technical,
they have innovated the world's first three temperature compartments.
The third compartment is designed to store the food that is the most important
to Americans.
What food is that now?
Not Pizza.
Anything else?
Ice Cream.
What's wrong when you take the ice cream out of the icebox?
It's too hard.
And Americans don't like to wait.
So it took a Chinese company to have this insight and then typical Chinese
innovation to invest the R and d money and were able to manufacture it in an
economical way.
So this is the typical innovation,
but they've now moving beyond this.
They're moving toward waterless washing machines,
for example.
So,
you know,
genuine technological innovations.
Chinese are very customer focused as well.
Um,
I'll just talk about the bottom ones.
We visited a number of startups,
so a suture,
nano,
micro worldclass nano products,
Svg,
Optronics,
they make security films over id cards and so on that are higher than the
quality you find in the USA on the European Union.
I'll talk about some of these other companies in a moment as well.
The entire ecosystem for Alibaba,
I'll talk more about good baby makes 80% of the world's baby carriages.
The typical innovation now are you hold the baby in one arm and one button that
you press folds up the baby carriage.
Again,
a typical Chinese innovation,
uh,
you have to invest in it requires significant manufacturing capability.
Now they start to make things sort of bit more technically advanced.
So 10 cent social networking,
instant messaging service,
online gaming and so on.
Medical devices are very big in China,
aging population.
Um,
and then in the intersection of online and medical devices are going to be very
big sector in China as well.
Sell me the mobile phone company sends out software upgrades every week based on
input from its millions of customers.
And then the bottom new software in example,
of integrating medical devices and information technology.
So just,
and these are organized,
uh,
to relate to each other.
So of course with the solar panels we have the,
um,
wind energy,
the third one,
they're now experimenting with roads using solar power to recharge the bus as it
drives along that also the typical Chinese innovation is that it requires a top
down government to put in that kind of innovation.
Can you imagine trying to do that in the streets of Cambridge,
Massachusetts of putting in a system like that on the top right.
Huawei for telecoms company now the largest telecoms equipment company in the
world.
Genuine innovation,
creating a product that ran two G,
three G and four G in one product.
Again,
typical Chinese orientation to the customer cause this was more practical for
the customer to have only one machine and now
investing more and more in r and d.
Uh,
it has r and d centers around the world,
for example,
outside Milan,
Italy.
It has a microwave,
a research technology center,
hiring Italian scientist,
keeping them in the local ecosystem,
the middle row,
high speed trains of course initially copied.
Um,
the Chinese chain company was sued by Siemens and Hitachi,
but there's breeze through that.
China of course,
has more high speed rail tracks and anywhere else in the world,
I don't think the US is a single mile of high speed rail.
Moses,
the United Kingdom.
And of course this means they also build more trains that are now innovating
with.
And I'm sending all the selling all over the world in the middle.
Aerial drones.
China did not invent aerial joins,
but most aerial drones and are manufactured in China.
And this is a product that's classically Susan for Chinese innovation in that
innovation for this product happens better next door to the factory.
Why?
Because innovations are,
you know,
to add more rotors to change the carrying capacity,
make it bigger,
make smaller.
There is now,
um,
a Chinese one that can carry a person.
Good luck traveling in that yourself one day.
Um,
and this is opposed to say something like a mobile,
a cell phone where you do the innovation in California and you haven't
manufactured in China.
So also this is a product that is based on metal,
plastics and some electronic combination.
Again,
ideal for the lower cost Chinese engineers and scientists.
And on the right,
this is the mid size jet that China has just has flown,
is going to go up against Boeing and Airbus.
Why is it able to do that?
Cause China buys more new jet aircraft than any other country in the world.
It already has 500 advanced orders before it is proven.
And of course most of those advanced orders are coming from Chinese airlines who
have to buy from this state owned a manufacturing initially copying but with
innovations that they're going to add.
And within forced technology chancellor from the West,
which is why we have this tariff wars just started in the last week or so now.
Uh,
the Internet based innovations are different.
The traditional innovations in China are based on low cost engineers for both R
and D and for manufacturing.
Wow.
That is less the case with Internet based companies where these mines
reputation,
and you know a lot more about this than I do,
is that Internet based innovation comes from experimentation with large numbers
of customers.
So China has more internet users than any other country in the world.
So this is now a great advantage for them.
And toward the end I'll show you some visuals about um,
the Internet ecosystems.
I won't go through the ones I said.
You can just look at the PDFs yourself.
So Arthur of model,
our theory of how this happened is that we have for drivers the ones in red and
pink and have three phases and yellow that old go through the first driver
customers.
Initially the customers were poorer,
so Chinese companies and western companies had to innovate in China in order to
develop products that were cheap enough.
Um,
the other thing we find is the Chinese customers are quite different than many
of their tastes from the West.
So again,
different types of products needed culture.
We have the entrepreneurial culture of Chinese executives and we include on the
culture,
the drive of the government.
The Chinese government really wants innovation now and the word innovation has
reached the top line of the latest five year plan and the made in China 2025
initiative is all about innovating in China rather than just manufacturing
on the right over time,
firms enhance their capabilities to innovate learning from western partners and
also as it became more profitable investing,
the cash that they generated in r and d and to other uses of the cash is setting
up foreign RND centers.
And thirdly,
buying foreign companies for that technology.
And I'll show you some examples of that.
So with this,
they moved from the phase one copying to fit for purpose to moving from being
followers to world standard products.
And in the third phase,
global expansion including acquisitions,
early acquisitions where resources like oil,
you know,
oil fields,
property.
But more and more they're making acquisitions for knowledge.
So here are some famous Chinese acquisitions.
Of course the first one was buying IBM personal computer business.
Then another example,
Volvo bought by a mid level Chinese company.
Most of you've never heard of called G Lee.
One of the reasons they able to buy Volvo is that the Chinese government
designated them as the only Chinese car company allowed to bid for Volvo.
They beat off the non-Chinese our competitors where when they won,
the CEO of Ge said it's like a Chinese peasant marrying a Hollywood movie star.
And of course they're starting to learn technology from Volvo,
puts my sister,
uh,
leading construction equipment company in Germany,
bought by now the world's largest construction equipment company.
China's Sonny [inaudible] Club Med,
which I think is for the,
uh,
large,
evolving leisure market in China.
Most controversial in the Middle Cooker in 2016,
a Chinese medical device company,
my dear,
bought one of Germany's leading robotics companies for the first time.
The government said,
really,
perhaps we shouldn't let this go.
And the Cha,
uh,
German prime minister,
asked a German consortium to outbid them,
but they were underbidding 20%,
and it went to China only on the right.
Finally,
last year,
um,
walls one German acquisition blocked x John under US pressure because it makes
semiconductors for,
uh,
some which goes into defense.
So the u s got Germany to block that acquisition,
but there'll be many more such acquisitions because the Chinese have,
uh,
a lot of money.
Uh,
Google is probably safe for now.
So the entire Chinese innovation ecosystem is growing.
In fact,
um,
the Chinese now have more scientific publications than the USA of course,
so far as quantity rather than quality.
But the quality will follow.
And of course it is the u s and the West that is training ethnic Chinese
scientists.
So if you're going to stem programs,
science,
technology,
engineering,
mathematics,
huge numbers of ethnic Chinese and China now has special government programs to
lure them back.
Also the market is doing the back.
We visited one company,
make flexible display screens,
replacing the something that,
you know,
a millimeter thick,
replacing the entire dashboard of a car,
started by a Chinese phd in electrical engineering from Stanford.
But he goes back to China to start the company because cars are being
manufactured in China and it's the biggest car market in the world,
right?
So everything you could system is on the up.
And here is the scariest side of I've come across.
It was presented at Oxford about a year and a half ago by someone representing
the Chinese Academy of Science 22 strategic science and technology initiatives,
uh,
that China's pursuing.
I'll just read out some of them.
Uh,
dark matter and dark energy,
controlling the structure of matter,
artificial life in synthetic biology,
nanoscience space science exploration,
ubiquitous sensing based information,
eyes manufacturing systems.
So they're actually going for everything pretty much.
China certainly has the world's largest super camp pewters for example.
All right,
so I'm summarizing our research.
We found that there were 10 major ways in which Chinese company innovation is
different from western innovation.
And you might think about how this is the same or different at Google as well.
I've got a slide or two on each one of these.
First one is a greater focus on local needs and customers.
Now all companies do this,
but the Chinese are really focused on local customers.
So on the left Chinese like soy products.
So joy young makes a soy milk cooker on the right.
That's myself with my coauthor.
We're at TCL,
the world's largest consumer electronics company.
They created a dual TV that two people can sit side by side watching two
completely separate TV programs,
full screen.
You just have to wear these dark glasses with the earpieces.
And my theory is that they designed this risk,
special Chinese need,
which is the single child policy.
The single child has grown up selfish and doesn't know how to share.
So when they get married,
they don't want to share TV programs either.
So this product is designed to reduce the divorce rate in China.
Apologies to the Chinese in this audience.
Oh,
and again,
a typical Chinese innovation that is expensive to design and it's expensive to
manufacturer,
but Chinese companies can afford to do that initially.
Number two,
acceptance of good enough standards.
This was the first mass market.
Chuck Car in China.
Chery Qq under 5,000 US dollars.
It was famous for its thousands of defects,
but the Chinese accepted it and if this had happened in the west,
the brand would be dead.
Cherry is still a respected brand in China.
So the Chinese are more forgiving at least initially,
um,
because they are still moving up the ladder,
but they didn't stop there.
So by participating in global supply chains,
they learned.
And furthermore,
because the competitive situation there is so fierce,
they're like Alison Wonderland with a red queen.
They've learned to run very fast to stay in the same place.
So,
um,
we now this concept of Red Queen Competition and this is what happens in China's
where enhancing their capabilities.
Third one,
incremental,
not radical innovations.
When I visited the head office of higher,
they show me their new range Cassata uh,
pretending not even to be Chinese called Cassata.
The main innovation is that they've embedded for Roski crystals on the front of
the cabinets.
So the Chinese are not embarrassed to do anything that will sell a product.
Another example of this,
of incremental,
um,
broad,
which starts out making gas.
Five air conditioners had,
has now gone into prefabricated buildings.
So I was in one of the buildings as was being built.
Notice they sell it like they actually talk about Lego.
You're going to buy this shape,
that shape fully sealed air conditioning systems.
When I stayed at their on campus hotel,
you can open the windows and there were no controls.
The air conditioning.
So a super energy efficient,
very fast to put up and much cheaper.
So that's again,
typical Chinese innovation,
willingness to supply special needs.
Um,
a TV company called high senses,
a big share of the TV market in Africa because in Africa many villages are too
poor and can't afford only one TV set,
which sometimes has to be shown outdoors for bigger audiences such as for a
football match,
this means that you need to make the screen brighter.
So high sense was willing to invest in a switch and the capability to make the
screen brighter for outdoor use and again to manufacturing.
So a typical Chinese innovation using large numbers staff.
One of our students at CIBS,
um,
started a security vehicle company.
Now at first security vehicles seem to be the opposite of what suitable for the
Chinese because the Chinese approach is to find a global product that same all
over the world,
manufactured in large quantities,
standardize at home and ship it around.
Well,
the problem security vehicles,
high regulated market,
so they're very different in different countries and small numbers,
batch production.
So what the CEO did,
okay,
he assigned 100 engineers to spend a year studying needs all over the world.
At the end of the year they came back and said,
you know what,
for each component,
the doors,
the windows,
the engines,
there are only about three or four variations.
So what he does now,
he manufactured the three or four variations of each component centrally and
then ships them around the world for final assembly.
So he is used large numbers of engineers to turn a multi local industry into a
global industry.
Six,
they worked their staff much harder.
They,
there's no work life balance in China.
I love some of these comments from the CEO of Huawei.
Huawei.
People are destined to work hard for a lifetime and to suffer more than others.
How's that for a recruiting slogan?
Um,
and uh,
you know,
bootcamp not much googling us and Chinese companies.
The and the sleeping.
What's underneath the desk,
the sleeping role.
So,
um,
yeah,
seventh.
Oh,
by the way,
I,
and I know about,
oh,
I'm working hard.
Well,
I'll give you an example.
I have a fast trial and error,
very pragmatic.
So don't say helping the leader talks about crossing the river by feeling the
stones.
I'm the CEO of GM.
China talks about failing and a government sponsored direction.
Electric vehicle.
By the way,
I predict that China of course will be the first country in the world to be
serious about electric vehicles.
They have the need because the air pollution problem,
um,
they need a lot of vehicles and they're going to solve the chicken and egg
problem of the charging stations because with the top down government,
they are installing charging stations all over the country and they'll have
fourth incentives to make people buy electric vehicles,
uh,
rather than,
gasoline based ones.
MMM.
Less formal,
faster processes.
We found that everything in China is faster.
Specific example,
we're working with a major European multinational who bought a Chinese company
in one of its sectors and we help them compare the length of the innovation
process.
The European process was 24 months,
the Chinese process was 12 months.
So we then help them converge on an 18 month process to convince headquarters to
allow them to go from 24 months to 18 months.
They couldn't go to 12 months because the Chinese took too many shortcuts or a
10 cents.
Wechat,
the gray release 1 million user experiments that they're able to do.
Again,
the large numbers in China,
more intervention by the bosses.
You know,
China's very boss oriented in the West.
It's 90% process and 10 cent boss in China.
It's 30 cent process and 70% uh,
boss,
I'm on the right,
the CEO of broad,
he actually said to me,
I'm responsible for 95% of the innovations at broad.
That was an astonishing statement.
One,
if it's true and two that he should say it,
even Steve Jobs wouldn't have said that.
And I know Chinese bosses,
my father was a Chinese boss.
He once said to me,
son,
you should never contradict me,
especially when I'm wrong.
But
interestingly,
for those of you who are not Chinese,
even for myself,
I'm from Hong Kong originally,
you may think of the Chinese being very obedient.
Well,
Chinese are a billion only under some circumstances.
Chinese are very obedient when they are observed by a superior,
whether in a company or in a family setting where you know,
in a family is always a restaurant of superiority,
you know,
your,
your parents,
et cetera.
So,
um,
when they're not supervise the Chinese very disobedient,
hence the same shank out wonky un,
the mountain is high and the emperor is far way.
Now you can think about other cultures.
There are some cultures where people are very obedient,
whether or not they're observed.
He's the cultures,
for example,
where people stand at a red light when there are no cars around.
Alright,
class exams being Japan and Germany.
And there are other cultures,
national cultures where people are very disobedient,
whether or not they're observed.
And these are economic basket cases.
I don't even need to name the countries,
you can figure them out for yourselves.
But China is this on one diagonal.
And indeed there are some other cultures that I've experienced where people are
obedient.
If you don't observe them too much and they become disobedient if they feel
you're watching them too much.
And I found that to be true of the Netherlands and other Scandinavian cultures,
which,
which is Google.
Okay.
Is it more like the Scandinavian culture where you'd like to be left alone?
Right.
There's the Chinese are the exact opposite.
Oh,
close to the government.
Of course.
So Chinese companies benefit from having,
um,
a lot of government support.
So if we summarize this,
um,
China has a triple threat winning a trifecta there have the manufacturing
capability,
which India doesn't have,
even though India is the second one,
scientific and technical capacity,
China has more of that as well.
So China now on the second point,
can pretty much absorb most new technological and scientific development.
Yes.
Are still behind the u s but there is a rapid catch up,
particularly in digital,
for example,
and a huge domestic market as a result of which they can start an improve at
home before going global without necessarily bringing out worldclass products to
start with.
And they can challenge any global incumbents.
As I've shown in the case,
say of the commercial aircraft.
Even Japan could not go up against Boeing and Airbus,
but the Chinese state owned company is doing that.
This has happened only twice before in history,
which countries have these advantages?
First of all,
it was the British empire,
not bruising on his own,
but the entire empire give us the market.
And then of course the United States after the Second World War.
Now it is China's turn two of these three advantages.
If we now look at it from the viewpoint of Western companies,
we talk about why learn from China,
because China is an emerging lead market.
China's customers are young and extreme.
You know,
the concept of learning from,
uh,
extreme users in China,
they'll try anything.
So,
for example,
the way the Chinese learned to drink wine initially,
the Chinese mixed wine with Coca Cola to get used to it.
Um,
and tickling in food.
We see all kinds of innovations like that,
but they're now increasingly sophisticated or even leading demand.
There are now a lot of very wealthy young Chinese and that you will see them
around the streets of Boston as well.
The food,
her die,
the second generation rich,
they're probably not working at Google,
but uh,
they are the ones that are who,
who are buying the most expensive fashion.
China is pressing needs for solutions such as inclusion sign to lead the world.
Now in environmental solutions,
as I said before,
they're more forgiving because most people,
there are first generation or second generation consumers.
So they'll try things they weren't necessarily don't have to buy what their
parents bought.
And if you get something wrong,
they'll move on and forget the market.
Reasons among the world's biggest and most categories,
biggest for cars,
biggest four trains,
biggest for airplanes and so on.
And high diversity and differences even more so than in the United States
because of the temperature differences,
climatic differences,
uh,
specific examples.
Sun Yi,
the construction company said,
you know,
Western construction company might have two or three models per product such as
a crawler loaders,
but because of the diversity of soil conditions in China,
and because of the so many different building projects,
we'll have seven or eight different products instead.
So more innovation because of the size of the Chinese market and niche in China
can be a whole market in some western countries.
And then reverse innovation when you invent something for the Chinese market,
but it could be sent back to the developed world.
So the most famous example of that is general electrics.
Um,
ultra sound equipment.
Initially $150,000 machine if it was too expensive and complicated for Chinese
hospitals.
So Ge put together a team to create a handheld device that was about $20,000.
So succeeded in China,
but it's been reversed back to the u s not to displace the $150,000 machine,
but for new uses such as in doctors offices and in ambulances.
Thirdly,
competitors,
very intense competitors,
um,
breeding winners and they're assigned to go global as well.
So,
uh,
competition and China's fiercely,
even then in the USA.
So we summarize this by saying that um,
Western companies must learn some capabilities from China.
The first one,
bold experimentation and rapid iteration.
This particular choose say for Europe where companies have come too
conservative,
too much regulation,
they need to go to China to relearn bold experimentation.
Secondly,
innovation through creative adaptation,
adapting to create new products and new product categories,
lean value.
I mean all companies focus on lean value,
but even more so than China where it's more important.
And the fist one that we were quite surprised by is that whilst a Japan wasn't
much useful developing foreign managers because it's so ethnocentric,
China's very open to foreign manager.
So if you send someone there,
they get the chance to manage,
you know,
Chinese people,
people from other countries.
So we now have a saying to paraphrase a Frank Sinatra song,
Shanghai,
if you can manage there,
you can manage anywhere.
So,
um,
I'll just go through a few brief slides on ecommerce.
Uh,
China now has a bigger share of ie retail than anybody else in the world.
And by 2020 is predicted to have 60% of global e-commerce because Chinese live
on their mobile phones,
cell phones,
much more than other countries.
I mean,
I think Koreans are more,
but it's a much smaller country selected percentage of countries who've bought
something in the past 12 months.
China,
68% were ahead.
Uh,
I mean,
you know,
some of these statistics was,
it's your business,
but,
um,
so I won't search in internet and mobile payments.
Um,
third party mobile payments,
transaction value,
incredible speed of growth of this.
Uh,
some statistics on the types of products that they're buying.
Um,
and apple made a late entry into this and it's not doing that well compared with
the incumbents.
Um,
there's comparison here between Ali pay and we chats.
uh,
WeChat is starting to catch up with Ali pay.
The Green Line below are,
there's a comparison that you can look at.
Um,
and the last three sides,
three emerging disruptions.
This was created by one of my colleagues.
That's the rapid rise of connected on demand mobility and digital mobility.
So digital mobility,
very important in China.
Again,
some of you might expect because of the cities being so crowded,
the link between hardware innovation and the economics of the digital ecosystem,
China is more ready for this.
And then thirdly,
data driven insights.
So Chinese service businesses really mine their data and their emerging service
companies that are disrupting,
for example,
the,
uh,
automobile services.
So won't go through this,
but you can see that at least in mobility,
a lot of things going on.
And you can study this at,
you,
let at your leisure.
Um,
as you know,
most of you know,
Uber Lost Out in China,
right?
Defeated in China by the,
uh,
incumbent company and they ended up selling their state to the Chinese company
in exchange for a share in the combined,
uh,
business.
Uh,
one of the interesting,
the stakes that Uber made was that it was possible for the drivers to cheat
Uber.
And because if they got a friend to book a ride and then the friend canceled the
ride,
the driver's still got a percentage of the fee,
which was really dumb of Uber.
Because if in China there is a way for someone to cheat you,
they will.
And the last slide,
you know,
the famous bat,
you may have heard that phrase,
Baidu Alibaba 10 cent.
This last slide is about the ecosystems that they have built up.
So we have 15 to 20 minutes for questions.
Thank you for listening to this.
So you were just talking about data mining.
I had a question about that.
Um,
how did the privacy policies of the Chinese compared to Western countries,
what's privacy ability that the child,
no,
I'm serious.
Um,
the Chinese word for privacy has negative connotations.
It implies something a bit shameful that you want to hide.
My wife was English learn this when you know,
after getting married we went to Hong Kong and so that much less of a concept of
privacy.
And of course the government,
uh,
is entitle in China.
Governments entitled to look at any of your data.
All right.
Um,
it's uh,
yeah,
just like Facebook.
Um,
so privacy is much less,
uh,
well,
I mean,
do you guys know about the new development in China of the Good Citizen Index?
China's working to create a good citizen index,
definitely exact phrase,
but based on your behavior and after that you will be blocked from buying
airline tickets,
renting cars,
jobs,
et Cetera,
because you have a bad citizen behavior rating.
So no privacy.
Yeah.
I think I read somewhere that a part of the reason for China's expansion on like
mobile payments is because they don't have the existing infrastructure of credit
cards.
Are there any other examples where trying to kind of skip to pass something into
innovation?
Um,
yeah,
I mean that,
that,
that's the,
that's the best example.
I'm not injured,
not as the credit card infrastructure.
That end of the banking infrastructure.
So many Chinese,
very high percentage don't have bank accounts.
So they jumped,
they jumped straight to mobile.
Um,
so that's a big advantage.
Uh,
uh,
for them.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
a related example of this is,
you know,
bike rentals
in,
I don't know how much the are in the u s but you know,
in London and Paris we have these bike rental services,
but they've docking stations.
So Chinese companies invented,
uh,
bikes without docking stations.
It's done entirely digitally.
It locks the bike.
Uh,
so you can leave the bike anywhere.
Now,
there've been huge problems because they then get these mountains of discarded
bikes.
But in these,
again,
that's a different Chinese solution,
no infrastructure.
So they come up with a new solution where you can take the bike anywhere.
But,
so this is some of the examples of,
um,
the leapfrogging because they don't have the previous infrastructure.
Yep.
So your slide show kind of the ecosystem in China,
but there's a lot of technology that is forcibly not in China,
for example,
lots of restrictions on Google in China and we can't really have a presence due
to the government.
Have you looked at kind of the global usage by Chinese users of different
technology sets?
Well,
I mean,
the reason why Google is blocked in China,
I mean there are two reasons why Google is blocked in China.
One is the China wanted to protect its incumbent companies,
right?
And then secondly,
because Google was trying to protect the privacy of its users and China,
you know,
it doesn't like that,
that that's the,
that's the main thing.
Now,
yes.
Um,
not your exact question,
but it is a problem for Chinese researchers because of the blocks and access to
the Internet.
They cannot access everything they need to do.
So one of the solutions they have is that Chinese companies will open a research
office in Hong Kong where there are no blocks and then they do the Internet
search that way,
uh,
for a while.
Um,
researchers,
including business school professors,
um,
used,
I just blanked out,
you know,
this is a technology where you can get past this.
Now China's,
um,
what does it call the,
yeah.
VPN.
But now China is blocking that again and it's illegal to have VPN.
So,
uh,
I mean,
they're astonished thing when the Internet started was that people said there's
no way China can control this.
Uh,
but you know,
I think there's up to a million people working on controlling the internet.
So again,
this is use of the launch,
uh,
use of the large numbers.
So you mentioned that oftentimes Chinese students will come to the u s to get
educated and then there's incentives for them to go back to China.
And I've heard,
you know,
uh,
some people have the perspective like,
why should we educate if they're just going to take education and go back to
their country and not stay here and,
and,
you know,
contribute.
Um,
what,
how would you respond to that and what are your,
what are your,
what's your stance and thoughts on that?
Uh,
I mean that,
that's a complicated policy issue.
And,
um,
luckily I'm not a politician so I don't,
I don't know who's make these decisions.
I mean,
what we found through history is that you usually improve relations with a
country.
If you educate the people,
they go back with very positive views of the country.
Although interestingly,
20 years ago,
the Chinese would deliberately give very small living grants to the students.
They wanted them to experience the worst of the USA,
not the best of the USA.
They want them to live in the poorest places in the rest and not become too fond
of the u s I mean,
the Chinese students are now rich,
you know,
more of the ones that come out often have a wealthy parents.
So we're not having sort of the,
you often see these policy arguments out of the way around.
Why are countries like the UK and the u s throwing out these units after we've
invested in them and we want to keep them so you know,
it,
it's a,
it's a difficult solution.
I,
Donald Trump hasn't gone after that yet.
I think of blocking Chinese students,
but some who knows,
I think many people would argue that the longterm viability of China's,
um,
innovation is threatened by the increasing gap and social inequality.
Um,
and even,
you know,
those three huge companies,
a sucking up all of the ecosystem,
whereas perhaps others would argue that no Western economies have more room for
innovation because a of less regulation.
So I guess I could you comment on China's,
um,
the future of China is a innovation and then also how you see,
the uh,
growing a growing divide and uh,
the rich in China,
in the park in China,
the n the income and equality is triggered by what's called the who code system,
the residency system where you're not allowed to live in a city without getting
a special permit.
And in general the city's block that,
because once you're allowed,
then you can access all the services,
medical services,
education,
et cetera.
And so a lot of the,
uh,
lower level jobs in China I've done by people who are non residents who are
their semi illegally and Sadie,
their children cannot go to school.
So I have to leave the children back in the countryside be brought up by their
grandparents.
So this,
this is actually a massive problem that they literally don't know how to solve
right now,
affecting maybe 100 million people,
but I don't think that's necessarily going to,
uh,
block innovation per se because the innovation is happening at an upper level,
you know,
the scientists and the engineers.
Um,
secondly,
uh,
you know,
the nature of China is that it is state driven innovation,
but there are lots of private companies as well.
So many of them as individual companies like Alibaba Royal,
which I mentioned,
the flexible displacement,
these are strictly private companies that are sort of benefiting from the
Chinese innovation ecosystem.
And the question I haven't heard yet,
but people often ask me is,
well,
you know,
if China's like controlling people,
doesn't that,
uh,
stop innovation?
Well,
China
doesn't care so long as you do not see to overthrow the communist party.
If you're just innovating and making money,
they're happy to support you.
So I really don't necessarily see that as a problem or even by the dominance of
a few companies.
I'm sure look at the history of the u s um,
many industries have,
you know,
like the automobile industry from the 1930s onwards had been dominated by two or
three major companies.
In fact,
in China,
the problem isn't too many monopolies.
It's too many competitors.
We actually have coined a phrase in our next book with some different courses
about swarm innovation.
We have an article coming out soon about that.
There are swarms of Chinese competitors,
so there aren't two future and its competitors.
They're actually too many of them.
Uh,
what do you think are some of the challenges that are facing China and the space
and what are their leaders worrying about the most?
Well,
if I just talk about innovation,
um,
education system is inferior.
Um,
the education system top down traditional,
of course that doesn't stimulate so much innovation.
The Phd student will do the work of the professor,
et Cetera.
So they're aware of this and guess what?
They're paying the USA to help them solve the problem.
So Duke University has a program and China to teach Chinese university lectures
how to teach their students to be innovative.
Like the Americans.
So once again,
America is teaching China how to compete with America.
So that,
that is probably the biggest problem.
Um,
a secondary problem is the Chinese language,
which also affects,
you know,
the education system.
It's hard for other people to learn.
It takes up so much time and brain space of children.
I have my own personal prediction that mobile phones are helping to solve this
problem because more and more now people are using the cell phones to spell for
them.
Actually,
the older people are complaining about this,
but I could see this being outsourced to cell phones.
I want an area where the u s,
uh,
lags pretty severely behind the rest of the developed world is the healthcare
system.
And you've mentioned kind of in passing kind of the innovations in medical
technology and healthcare in China.
And I'm wondering what can the,
what can the US learn what and what can the u s take from that?
Um,
well,
China doesn't have a great healthcare system either.
It's surprisingly private.
Um,
people have to pay a lot.
So the whole,
you know,
uh,
state healthcare system has kind of withered away post,
post the Communists,
um,
economic economic system.
So,
you know,
you can get some services,
but for example,
people have to pay doctors on the side to get any serious treatment.
There's a terrible incentive in the doctors make money by selling medicines.
So they overprescribe their medicines.
But again,
they may,
going back to the technology part,
they may start to leapfrog this by you know,
digital etc. And making it faster.
I did have one experience myself.
I had to go through a health check.
And again,
typical Chinese approach,
it was like a production line,
whereas in the west I'd have gone,
you know,
from floor to floor to the x Ray Department to the blood department and so on.
Here it was a small building with a corridor,
first room,
chest x rays,
second room,
blood tests,
third room I test.
So it's like production line and the whole thing costs 100 US dollars.
We've cost you $1,000 in the u s yeah.
Uh,
we all know China is,
uh,
had largest market in the ward.
And,
uh,
for many things,
so many Western company,
how tried to enter the market without much success?
What's your view on the top reasons why Western company off of the field in
their market?
Good question,
but to be fair,
many companies have also succeeded.
Okay.
So,
um,
reasons for failure.
If you go up,
if you go into a sector where the Chinese were,
China's trying to develop its own competitors,
they'll make life very difficult for you,
right?
Because they can put,
they have hidden regulations they can pull out to make it difficult for you.
So long as you are contributing something that China doesn't have,
such as the western auto companies over the last 30 years,
that happy to welcome you.
I mean,
it's,
I teach international business.
It's the same principle.
You've got to bring something to the country that they don't have.
So,
um,
if you have that,
then they will welcome you and not make life,
uh,
not make life too difficult then you know,
partners for a long time you needed a Chinese partner somewhere.
Good partners.
Uh,
some were bad.
Um,
there's a Chinese thing,
uh,
Tom Tran Jima,
same bed,
different dreams.
So,
you know,
um,
so sometimes the partner was a nightmare,
so to speak,
following that analogy.
And so that's a reason why it could go wrong.
But really,
you know,
I think Google's case,
you actually came right up against a essential policy of the government,
which is the privacy issue and that's why you've been banned from China plus
secondarily,
you know,
um,
other companies like Ebay,
not a privacy issue.
Days wanted to protect the emerging,
they're emerging companies.
That's why.
So there are still opportunities but not in areas like that.
So
one thing I've noticed about competition in China,
it's a,
it's a very free willing from form of competition ready.
If you have any idea,
they will be a million competitors doing the same thing,
maybe better,
maybe not.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
that's a very hard situation for external companies,
right?
Because you know,
here in the US for example,
there is a strong law,
you know,
feel of,
of,
you know,
patents and Ip protection.
Right?
Um,
so how,
how can anyone think of,
uh,
you know,
getting into marketing in China in such a situation where there is a feeling
that everybody will,
everything will be swollen,
right?
Yes.
Actually what Western companies are doing more and more is that instead of
selling products,
they're now selling a business models.
Um,
so if we can embed the product in a business system that is much harder to
imitate against,
um,
so,
uh,
you know,
selling the service based on the product rather than the product itself or
rapidly innovating to keep ahead of the imitators or having superior tech having
superior technology,
there are ways to protect your intellectual property so that it can't be,
it can't be fully imitated.
Interestingly,
they also,
companies are still ahead in China.
This maybe a good item to finish with actually that,
um,
as told by one of the German automotive companies,
they said,
the reason we're still ahead is that in the west,
the auto engineers grew up being taken to repair garages by their father or
their grandfather.
So they've,
you know,
they've had this since childhood,
these automotive engineers in China,
the automotive engineers are first generation.
They don't have this deep background and cars are this very complex combination
of being a consumer product and being a highly engineered technical products.
And actually they're going to have more difficulty in cars then they have say in
commercial jet aircraft.
And in fact usually in,
cause,
you know,
they don't particularly want the ultimate driving machine BMW.
They want the ultimate mobile living room because that,
that's a different um,
uh,
kind of experience that they,
that they want in China.
Um,
I'll give you,
there's a great story about BMW,
which is that in China,
um,
this will be my last comment.
There was a dating TV program in China,
just to show you again,
Chinese culture and young woman on the CRM and was asked by young man,
he said,
you know,
I,
I'm not very rich,
so would you go on a date with me just on a bicycle and her apply?
She rejected him and said,
I'd rather cry on the back of a BMW than smile on top of a bicycle.
So that's Chinese culture.
Thank you very much.